Donc là nous sommes dans la leçon 5, la réponse de la Bible à l'estime de soi.
Nous avons commencé, donc si vous vous souvenez, les premiers cours, le premier cours même, je l'avais même donné,
nous avons commencé ce cours, l'ensemble de ce cours donc, en définissant la peur de l'homme.
La peur de l'homme se manifeste lorsque nous orientons notre vie autour du pouvoir que les autres exercent sur nous plutôt que le pouvoir de Dieu.
Ce pouvoir, ça peut être les perceptions que les gens ont de nous, ça peut être les paroles, les actions ou tout ce que nous ressentons comme un besoin d'eux.
Ensuite, donc sur la suite de la leçon, nous avons examiné l'inverse, la peur de Dieu.
La peur de Dieu, c'est lorsque nous orientons notre vie autour de lui.
Nous avons étudié trois formes courantes de peur de l'homme.
C'est la peur d'être exposé, d'être rejeté, d'être blessé.
Et la dernière fois, donc la semaine dernière, avec notre frère Nathanael, nous nous sommes posé la question, de quoi avons-nous vraiment besoin ?
Ou plus précisément, de quelle manière avons-nous besoin des autres ?
Nous avons vu que la réponse ne réside pas tant dans un besoin psychologique d'être aimé.
Nous avons plutôt besoin des autres pour accomplir le dessein de Dieu pour nous.
Ça, c'était la réponse finale.
C'est-à-dire, le dessein de Dieu, c'est de montrer combien il est extraordinaire.
Le dessein de Dieu, c'est de porter l'image de Dieu.
Donc, cela signifie que notre besoin des autres n'est pas tant d'être aimé que d'aimer.
C'est très différent d'un besoin qui est égocentrique, parce que le besoin égocentrique, c'est le besoin qu'on a d'être aimé,
et qui conduit finalement à nous orienter vers les autres plutôt que vers Dieu.
Donc, à un moment, on va orienter une crainte de l'homme, parce qu'on a ce besoin d'être aimé,
plutôt que d'être aimé, plutôt d'être orienté vers Dieu.
Donc, aujourd'hui, nous allons aborder, après avoir abordé cette question,
quel est notre besoin et quelle est notre perception par rapport aux besoins que nous pouvons avoir des autres ?
Aujourd'hui, nous allons nous poser la question, avec cette prise,
quel est le rôle de l'estime de soi dans la vie d'un chrétien ?
Donc, nous avons lu le passage de Corinthiens 9.
Et la première chose, donc ça, c'était l'introduction.
Nous allons déjà aborder le deuxième point.
Le deuxième point, je vais vous présenter, ça c'est un peu ce que nous voyons au niveau de la société.
Donc là, on va voir un peu, dans notre société à nous, comment on définit l'estime de soi.
Ensuite, on va voir aussi en quoi l'estime de soi, en tant que tel, n'apporte pas plus de solutions à l'homme.
Et nous allons voir qu'il y a quelque chose de meilleur que l'estime de soi.
Et on finira avec trois types de luttes que nous pouvons avoir par rapport à trois types de luttes qui se développent dans notre vie,
vis-à-vis de l'estime de soi.
Donc, par exemple, surtout dans notre société aujourd'hui, si on a moins de 50 ans, on va dire,
qu'on a grandi ici en France, ou même dans beaucoup d'autres pays européens,
nous avons probablement été éduqués dès notre plus jeune âge à comprendre le besoin de l'estime de soi.
Donc aujourd'hui, c'est quelque chose qui est beaucoup mis en avant.
Si vous allez sur les réseaux sociaux, on va beaucoup parler de l'estime de soi.
Tout cela, ça va venir des préjugés.
Il y a des préjugés fondamentaux qu'on va trouver au travers des commentaires à la télévision,
au travers de ce qu'on va trouver dans les romans qu'on va lire,
les cours à l'école, les préjugés des gens, les préjugés des amis.
Et donc, on va dire à un moment que si vous voulez être heureux,
si vous voulez être bien dans votre peau, si vous voulez réussir,
vous devez commencer par vous aimer.
Donc ça, c'est le principe, un moment de l'estime de soi.
Un moment, on va dire aujourd'hui, pour que tu sois heureux,
il faut déjà que tu arrives à t'aimer toi-même.
Combien de fois on a pu entendre dans notre vie, je me respecte.
Donc à un moment, aujourd'hui, beaucoup de personnes aussi vont dire,
je me sens bien parce que je me respecte.
Et même lorsque les personnes sont en train de mettre ces choses en avant,
on va voir que malgré l'assurance avec laquelle ils sont en train de mettre en avant,
que pour eux, si déjà ils s'aiment, si déjà ils ont cette estime de soi-deux,
malgré l'assurance qu'ils mettent, on va souvent voir que c'est quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus ambitieux qu'objectif.
Donc, pour les personnes qui vont lutter contre la peur de l'homme,
c'est une solution de base à laquelle beaucoup de personnes ont recours, consciemment ou non.
Ils vont se dire à un moment, si je me sentais mieux dans ma peau,
je me ficherais.
Donc ça, c'est un peu, je parle en termes français,
je vais me ficher de ce que les gens pensent.
Si je m'aimais vraiment, je serais bien quand me rejette ou pas.
Et bien sûr, le problème que beaucoup d'entre nous avons,
c'est que beaucoup d'entre nous, on ne va pas bien se sentir dans notre peau.
Au fond de nous-mêmes, sur beaucoup d'aspects,
on ne va pas se sentir à la hauteur lorsque nous traversons certaines choses.
Et ce sera intéressant aussi parce que quand nous allons arriver au point 5,
vous allez voir un moment que quand nous développons certaines questions,
nous allons voir qu'il y a beaucoup de choses dans nos vies
où nous réalisons un moment que malgré tout ce que nous voulons nous donner
en termes d'estime de soi,
il y a beaucoup de choses qui bataillent contre ça.
Et donc, même dans les milieux chrétiens,
aujourd'hui, il y a beaucoup cette influence de l'estime de soi.
D'ailleurs, aujourd'hui, c'est beaucoup lié avec le développement personnel.
C'est ce principe, un moment que je dois accomplir mon potentiel.
Je dois être ce que je suis.
Je me respecte, je m'aime.
Alors Dieu bénira et Dieu va même chasser les mauvaises influences autour de moi.
Donc, on peut même donner à la solution de l'estime de soi une allure très chrétienne.
Après tout, certains vont même se souvenir de ce que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ avait,
on va dire, énoncé comme une règle d'or,
lorsqu'il va dire, par exemple, aime ton prochain comme toi-même.
Et donc, certains vont dire, apprenez d'abord à vous aimer vous-même
et vous serez alors prêts à aimer votre prochain.
Ça, c'est même beaucoup, beaucoup de...
J'ai même encore lu ça cette semaine en regardant.
C'était drôle, j'étais en train de préparer le cours.
Mais en lisant même sur les réseaux sociaux, voilà, c'est cet aspect-là.
Si je m'aime, alors je pourrais aimer les autres.
Et ils vont même dire, Jésus vous a tant aimé qu'il est mort pour vous.
Il a vu votre valeur.
Mais aussi beau que cela puisse paraître,
ce n'est pas chrétien du tout.
Et nous allons essayer de dégager un peu de vérité de ce concept fondamental
par rapport à l'estime de soi.
Mais une première question qu'on peut déjà se poser,
pour vous, on peut déjà se poser cette question,
quels sont les problèmes fondamentaux
qui sont liés à la lutte contre la peur de l'homme par l'estime de soi ?
Quels sont les problèmes fondamentaux qui se posent
lorsqu'on va parler un moment de l'estime de soi
vis-à-vis de la crainte de l'homme ?
Parce que c'est aussi le sujet.
C'est de voir à un moment comment notre crainte de Dieu,
notre crainte de l'homme,
est aussi impactée par l'estime de soi.
Donc ça, ce sont des points.
On va voir maintenant ce point 3, ce point 4 là-dessus.
Et déjà, lorsqu'on va parler par rapport à la crainte de l'homme,
l'estime de soi, c'est une bataille qui est déjà perdue d'avance.
Je vais vous énumérer quelques points,
quelques défauts fatals de l'estime de soi
comme solution à la peur de l'homme.
Parce que souvent, on va ériger l'estime de soi.
Si j'ai assez d'estime de soi,
si j'ai assez d'estime pour me faire respecter,
alors l'homme, je n'aurai pas à avoir peur de l'homme.
Le problème, la source de ces choses,
c'est que ce sont des choses qui restent toujours,
on va même aborder,
ce sont des choses où on essaye toujours de résoudre un problème
qu'on pense être extérieur,
alors que le problème, il est toujours intérieur.
Donc déjà, l'estime de soi,
en tant que tel,
dans cet aspect,
cet aspect d'estime de soi
comme solution face à la peur de l'homme,
ce n'est pas biblique.
Quand le Seigneur Jésus-Christ a dit
d'aimer son prochain comme soi-même,
il supposait déjà
que nous, on s'aimait déjà beaucoup.
Lorsqu'il est en train de dire
« Aime ton prochain »,
c'est que le problème que nous avions à un moment,
c'est que nous étions déjà trop centrés sur nous-mêmes.
L'aspiration n'est pas l'amour de soi,
mais l'amour du prochain.
Quand on parle déjà
de cet aspect d'amour,
donc déjà quand on parle de l'estime de soi,
qui est de faire l'effort de nous aimer nous-mêmes,
le problème qu'il y a déjà dans notre vie,
c'est qu'on s'aime même déjà trop.
Et voilà pourquoi on va justifier à un moment le péché.
On peut reprendre cet aspect,
parce que j'ai parlé de cet aspect
où certains vont dire à un moment
que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
est mort pour nous
parce que nous avions de la valeur,
mais c'est tout le contraire.
Quand nous lisons Romains 5,
et nous pouvons lire rapidement,
quand nous lisons Romains 5,
Romains 5 au verset 6,
il nous est dit
« Car lorsque nous étions encore sans force,
Christ autant marqué est mort pour des impies. »
Donc, le problème qu'il y a,
c'est que nous n'étions pas
en train d'avoir de la valeur.
Nous étions pécheurs.
Nous étions ennemis de Dieu.
Ce n'est même pas que nous étions des pécheurs
avec un grand potentiel.
L'une des grandes leçons de la vie chrétienne
que nous devons voir à un moment,
et nous l'avons lu dans le passage
qui est en référence dans 2 Corinthiens 12,
l'une des grandes leçons de la vie chrétienne,
c'est que nous devons nous glorifier
de notre faiblesse,
même lorsque nous sommes enfants
rachetés de Dieu.
Le message de l'Évangile n'est pas
« Courage, tu es meilleur
que ce que tu peux penser de toi. »
Le message de l'Évangile,
c'est de nous rappeler à un moment
que nous sommes bien pires
que ce que nous pensons de nous-mêmes.
Le message de l'Évangile,
c'est que
le fait que nous réalisons
un moment que nous sommes bien pires
que ce que nous pouvions penser de nous-mêmes,
cela compte bien plus
que ce que nous pouvons craindre.
Mais, le message de l'Évangile aussi,
c'est de nous dire à un moment
que nous sommes beaucoup plus aimés
que ce que nous pouvons imaginer.
vous saisissez ?
C'est
« Je ne suis pas meilleur
que ce que je pense. »
Parce qu'aujourd'hui,
l'estime de soi qui rentre dans l'Église,
c'est que tu es meilleur
que ce que tu penses,
tu as un potentiel.
Non.
La Bible dit à un moment,
le potentiel ne se trouve pas en nous.
Le potentiel se trouve en Christ
qui est mort pour nous
alors que nous étions pécheurs.
Donc, la réalité à un moment,
c'est que plus nous avançons
dans notre marche avec Christ,
et plus nous réalisons
combien nous sommes pires
que ce que nous pensions.
Et pendant que nous sommes
en train de réaliser cela,
pendant que nous sommes en train
de réaliser combien nous sommes pires
que ce que nous pensions,
nous sommes en train de réaliser
que nous sommes beaucoup plus aimés
que ce que nous pouvions imaginer.
Donc ça, c'est ce premier aspect
de voir un moment
que la solution de l'estime de soi
pour affronter la peur de l'homme
n'est pas biblique,
parce que finalement,
elle suppose un moment
qu'il nous faut découvrir un potentiel
où on va s'aimer nous-mêmes,
mais ce que nous réalisons au moment,
c'est qu'en tant que pécheurs,
quand le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
nous dit de nous aimer,
d'aimer notre prochain,
c'est parce que nous-mêmes,
nous étions déjà trop centrés sur nous.
Donc, on voit que ce n'est pas biblique.
Un deuxième point
où l'estime de soi
est une bataille perdue d'avance,
c'est que ça ne marche pas.
Ce qui est intéressant pour nous,
c'est de voir comment la vérité biblique
se révèle toujours dans la vie réelle.
À un moment,
on peut mettre en avant
ces aspects d'estime de soi.
Il y a des personnes
qui vont vous présenter un moment,
maintenant, je suis heureux
parce que j'ai appris à me respecter.
Je vois beaucoup
dans les mouvements féministes
où ça, à un moment,
j'ai appris à me respecter,
j'ai appris à faire,
je suis heureuse dans tout ça.
Mais, par exemple,
ça, c'était une référence
qui disait, par exemple,
depuis,
il y avait un livre
qui a été un peu un livre moteur
pour toucher l'Occident
par rapport à ça.
C'est un livre qui s'appelait
La psychologie de l'estime de soi
qui est sorti en 1969.
Là, je n'ai pas le nom de l'auteur,
mais depuis,
le monde occidental a été inondé,
on va dire,
de ce mantra,
le mantra de l'estime de soi.
Donc, voilà,
c'est devenu avec le développement personnel.
Et vous voyez que
ce n'était pas d'abord à l'Église.
Donc, aujourd'hui,
on présente ça comme étant
quelque chose de l'Évangile.
Ce n'est pas l'Évangile.
Ça a infiltré les Églises
au fur et à mesure des années.
Et donc, par contre,
on a pu même recenser que depuis,
donc, le livre est sorti en 1969.
De 1970 à l'an 2000, par exemple,
il y a eu au moins 15 000 articles
qui ont été publiés
sur le lien entre l'estime de soi
et à peu près tout dans la vie.
Si vous regardez même,
on va l'estime de soi,
on va à un moment lier
l'estime de soi au bonheur,
on va lier l'estime de soi aux notes
au niveau du travail ou de l'école,
on va lier l'estime de soi
à la maîtrise de soi
et beaucoup d'autres choses.
Même dans le mariage.
Mais ces dernières années,
et là, c'est ce que je disais à un moment,
la vérité biblique se réalise toujours.
À un moment,
ce principe de l'estime de soi,
c'est de dire à un moment
que l'homme dit vrai
et que Dieu est menteur.
Mais la parole de Dieu nous dit
à un moment que Dieu dit vrai
et que l'homme est menteur.
Et ce que nous constatons,
d'un point de vue scientifique,
par exemple,
les scientifiques ont constaté,
en voyant même tous ces articles
qui sont sortis,
en regardant les vies des personnes en étudiant,
la critique scientifique
a vu à un moment
que l'estime de soi n'améliore
ni les notes,
ni les perspectives de carrière.
Par exemple,
pour prendre un exemple
au niveau de l'école,
les étudiants
dont l'estime de soi est loué,
donc à un moment,
quand il y a des étudiants
qui mettent en avant
l'estime de soi dans leur vie,
on va remarquer à un moment
qu'ils deviennent plus réticents
à prendre des risques,
ils obtiennent de moins bons résultats.
Lorsque des étudiants
au bord de l'échec
reçoivent beaucoup d'éloges
qui vont renforcer leur estime de soi,
leurs notes vont encore plus chuter.
Et on a, par exemple,
remarqué au niveau scientifique
que les groupes démographiques
qui ont la meilleure opinion d'eux-mêmes
sont les moins heureux.
Donc, par exemple,
vous allez voir à un moment
que c'est quelque chose
qui est très répandu en Occident,
cet aspect de l'estime de soi,
et pourtant,
l'Occident,
c'est en Occident
qu'on consomme le plus
d'antidépresseurs,
c'est en Occident
où on a le taux de suicide
le plus élevé,
mais pourtant,
c'est celui où on met
le plus en avant
l'estime de soi.
On peut même remarquer
à un moment
que les personnes
très agressives et violentes,
ce sont des personnes
qui ont une très haute opinion
d'elles-mêmes.
Et donc, par là,
ça réfute même la théorie
selon laquelle l'agressivité
peut être utilisée
pour compenser
une faible estime de soi.
Parce que souvent,
on va dire à un moment
que c'est parce qu'il a
une estime de soi très faible
qu'il est agressif.
Non, souvent,
c'est des personnes
qui sont trop sûres d'elles
qui vont beaucoup plus être
dans l'agressivité,
dans la violence,
parce que l'estime de soi
les amène à se tromper
sur elles-mêmes.
Donc ça,
c'était le point 2,
un moment de voir,
un moment que ce...
On est dans le grand 3,
on est toujours
dans le grand 3,
mais l'estime de soi
qui est une bataille perdue
en tant que crainte
vis-à-vis de l'homme.
Et le troisième point,
c'est un peu ce que je viens
de dire en parlant
de Dieu qui dit vrai
et l'homme qui est menteur,
nous savons que ce n'est pas vrai.
Même au-dedans de nous.
Il y a une citation
d'Abraham Lincoln
que j'avais même déjà lu
plusieurs fois
et que j'ai reprise là,
par exemple.
Abraham Lincoln disait
à un moment,
on peut tromper
certaines personnes
tout le temps
et tout le monde
une partie du temps.
Donc là,
on peut tromper
certaines personnes
tout le temps
et tout le monde
une partie du temps,
mais on ne peut pas
tromper tout le monde
tout le temps.
et même nous-mêmes,
on ne peut pas se tromper.
Si aujourd'hui,
une vie heureuse,
une vie réussie
dépendait de notre certitude
que nous sommes
des personnes formidables,
alors nous sommes
dans une situation délicate.
Mais si vous regardez
la vie des personnes,
si je dis à un moment
que je suis une personne
formidable,
ce n'est pas pour autant
que ma vie
va être formidable.
Ce n'est pas pour autant
que je vais bien éduquer
mes enfants,
que je vais bien
prendre soin de ma femme.
Au contraire,
le risque qu'il y a même,
c'est que je sois
encore plus orgueilleux
parce que comme je suis
une personne formidable,
même lorsque les autres
sont en train
de pointer mes erreurs,
ce sont les autres
qui sont un problème.
Moi, je suis très bien.
Et c'était même
souvent drôle
quand on a des personnes
qui vont...
J'ai écouté des personnes
qui se plaignaient
un moment.
Vous pouvez avoir
une personne
qui va avoir
des soucis avec...
Il a eu un souci
en février avec quelqu'un.
En mars,
il a le même problème
avec un autre.
En avril,
il a le même problème
avec un autre.
Mais quand tu discutes
avec lui,
ce sont toujours
les autres
qui sont le problème
parce qu'il a
une haute estime de lui.
Lui pense à un moment
qu'il est toujours droit
dans tout ce qu'il fait.
Ce sont les autres
qui ont tort.
Mais ce qu'il y a,
c'est que nous ne pouvons
pas mentir à Dieu.
Et ça nous amène
à une question cruciale.
Comment un chrétien
devrait-il réagir
au sentiment d'infériorité?
Comment...
Comment on doit
comprendre le fait
que nous dire
à un moment
que nous allons,
nous sommes vraiment bien
ou que nos enfants
vont vraiment bien,
que nous-mêmes
nous allons vraiment bien.
Comment nous allons
réaliser à un moment
que ce n'est pas la solution?
Mais la solution,
parce que le problème
du cœur de l'homme,
c'est que malgré
tout ce qu'il peut mettre
en avant de l'estime de soi,
les conséquences du péché
frappent toujours dans la vie.
Mais donc,
l'estime de soi
n'est pas une solution.
Elle n'est pas une solution
vis-à-vis de la crainte
de l'homme.
Elle est beaucoup plus
en train de renforcer cela.
Mais il y a quelque chose,
et là nous abordons
le point 4,
il y a quelque chose
qui est mieux
que l'estime de soi.
Laissez-moi vous donner
un élément
frappant de ce cours.
La réponse de la Bible
à l'estime de soi
n'est pas de nous donner
une méthode,
je vais dire une méthode
jésunienne,
si on peut dire comme ça,
pour nous sentir mieux
dans notre peau.
Elle ne veut pas nous dire
que maintenant
que nous sommes en Christ,
nous sommes enfin
la personne qui est belle
et noble que nous avons
toujours rêvé d'être.
Au contraire,
la Bible est honnête.
La Bible nous dit
qu'en dehors de Christ,
nous sommes méchants
et rebelles contre Dieu.
Et même maintenant
que nous sommes devenus
chrétiens,
notre valeur ne réside
pas dans nos capacités
parce que nos capacités
sont souillées
par le péché.
Au contraire,
nous avons de la valeur
en tant que toile
sur laquelle Dieu
peut déployer
ses capacités.
Notre valeur
n'est pas intrinsèque,
non,
elle est dérivée.
Ça veut dire
que notre valeur
ne se trouve pas en nous,
notre valeur
est une valeur dérivée
qui vient
de la grâce de Dieu.
Notre valeur,
c'est une valeur incroyable.
La valeur que nous portons
aujourd'hui,
c'est une valeur incroyable.
Mais le problème
des hommes
et souvent même
de certains chrétiens,
c'est de nous tromper
sur l'origine
de cette valeur,
c'est de nous tromper
sur l'importance
de cette valeur.
Quand vous voyez
un podcast
de quelqu'un
qui se dit croyant
et qui va dire
à un moment
tu as de la valeur,
tu as du potentiel,
libère tes capacités,
accomplis ce que tu veux
dans ta vie.
et chasse
les gens négatifs
qui t'empêchent
de pouvoir réussir.
Ça,
vous savez déjà
que ce n'est pas biblique.
Ils sont en train
de se tromper
de la source
de la valeur.
Bien sûr,
cette personne a une valeur.
Si on s'adresse
à un chrétien,
un chrétien a une valeur.
Mais notre valeur,
ce n'est pas une valeur
qui est propre à nous.
C'est une valeur
qui tourne autour de Dieu.
La réponse de la Bible
par rapport
au mouvement
de notre estime de soi,
c'est que le but
de notre vie
est de faire honneur
à Christ.
Le but de notre vie,
c'est de mettre en valeur
la grande valeur
de Christ en nous
et non la nôtre.
Rappelons-nous
de ce passage
que nous avons lu
et je vais même dire
dans 2 Corinthiens 12,
et voici la bonne nouvelle
pour nous.
En faisant cela,
même quand nous sommes honnêtes
quant à nos propres faiblesses,
nous trouverons toujours
tout ce que le mouvement
que Dieu nous donne
pour l'estime de soi promis.
On peut,
par rapport à toutes ces choses,
nous allons voir
à un moment
que ce que Dieu nous donne
en Christ,
c'est ce que l'estime de soi
nous promet.
L'estime de soi nous promet
de la paix,
de la joie,
du bonheur,
de l'épanouissement,
de l'amour,
de la liberté.
Toutes ces choses,
nous les trouvons en Christ.
Nous trouvons une paix
que le monde
ne peut pas nous donner.
Nous trouvons une joie
que nous ne pouvons pas
trouver ici-bas.
Donc, nous voyons
ces éléments-là.
Mais,
qu'est-ce que la Bible
va nous mettre
à un moment ?
La Bible nous dit
à un moment
qu'au lieu de rechercher
ces choses
en valorisant
notre propre personne,
nous allons trouver
ces choses
lorsque nous sommes en train
de valoriser Dieu.
quel est le passage
qui nous permet ?
Un des passages,
parce que si je dis
le passage,
ce n'est pas le seul,
un des passages
qui nous permet
de comprendre cela,
c'est Matthieu 6,
verset 33.
« Mais cherchez d'abord
le royaume et la justice
de Dieu
et toutes ces choses
vous seront données
par-dessus. »
Cherchez d'abord
la justice
et le royaume des cieux.
Si nous sommes en train
de chercher Dieu,
si nous sommes en train
de valoriser Dieu
dans nos vies,
alors toutes ces choses
que les hommes
sont en train de chercher
au travers de l'estime de soi,
nous allons les trouver
en Christ.
Donc, la question n'est pas
de mettre en avant
notre valorisation à nous,
la question est de mettre
en avant le fait
de glorifier Dieu
dans nos vies,
de mettre Christ en valeur.
Et quand nous prenons
par exemple cet exemple
où on va voir des podcasts
où on va dire
à un moment
« Éliminez les gens
négatifs de votre vie. »
Si c'était le cas,
pourquoi Dieu a donné
le peuple d'Israël à Moïse ?
Pourquoi Moïse a dû
un moment composer
avec le peuple d'Israël ?
Pourquoi Dieu a préparé
Moïse pendant tant d'années ?
Dieu a préparé Moïse.
Moïse a d'abord
échoué la première fois
parce qu'il n'était pas prêt.
Et Dieu l'a conduit
très loin.
Dieu l'a conduit même
à élever les animaux.
Vous savez,
élever des moutons
et une des choses
les plus difficiles
d'une vie.
À un moment,
quand les moutons
décident de se jeter
d'une montagne,
ils se jettent d'une montagne.
Ils ont une telle bêtise
à un moment
que si ça les prend,
ils ne vont même pas
voir l'obstacle.
Être berger n'est pas facile.
Mais Dieu a fait
de Moïse un berger.
Pourquoi ?
La finalité,
ce n'était pas
qu'il reste berger.
C'était pour prendre soin
du peuple d'Israël
plus tard.
Pour lui donner le cœur
qui lui permettrait
de pouvoir prendre
soin du peuple d'Israël.
Donc Dieu ne lui a pas
enlevé la difficulté.
Comme on va dire à un moment,
enlève les gens négatifs
de ta vie.
D'ailleurs,
ils sont même moins négatifs
que la personne même
qui est censée croire
qu'elles sont négatives.
Proverbe 29, verset 25,
nous l'avions lu au début
de la première leçon.
La crainte des hommes
tend un piège,
mais celui qui se confie
en l'éternel est protégé.
Donc l'accent
qui est mis là en avant,
quand on va par exemple
chercher d'abord
le royaume
et la justice de Dieu,
toutes ces choses
vous seront données
par-dessus tout.
La crainte des hommes
tend un piège,
mais confiez-vous
en l'éternel.
Donc, ce que Dieu
est en train de nous dire
pour vaincre
le complexe d'infériorité
ou même un complexe
de supériorité
qui pourrait venir
dans notre vie,
ayant confiance
en l'éternel.
Concentrons-nous
sur Dieu
et non sur nous-mêmes.
Soumettons-nous
avec joie
au dessein de Dieu
pour nous.
Donc, à un moment,
Dieu peut mettre
des personnes difficiles
dans notre vie
pour que nous apprenions
à être brisés,
non pas pour que nous
soyons mis en valeur
mais pour que Christ
soit mis en valeur en nous.
Apprenons à nous contenter
de la manière
dont Dieu a choisi
de manifester sa puissance
dans notre vie,
même lorsqu'il le fait
par la faiblesse,
parce que nous avons
été créés
à l'image
de Dieu
pour le glorifier,
pour le vanter,
pas pour nous vanter
et nous mettre en avant.
L'un des meilleurs passages
pour le constater,
c'est donc ce passage
que nous avons lu
dans 2 Corinthiens.
dans 2 Corinthiens 12,
l'apôtre Paul parle
de ce qu'il appelle
une sorte d'écharde
dans la chair.
Alors, l'écharde,
on n'a pas de référence
et bien sûr,
là, le Saint-Esprit
aussi dans sa sagesse
n'a pas voulu
nous donner plus d'indications.
Est-ce que l'écharde
dans la chair de Paul,
est-ce que c'était
la solitude ?
Est-ce que c'était
la maladie ?
un handicap ?
Est-ce que c'était
une tentation ?
Nous n'avons pas
de réponse là-dessus.
Mais nous voyons
qu'à trois reprises,
Paul a supplié
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
de lui retirer
cette faiblesse.
Il n'a peut-être
pas fait ça
pour des raisons égoïstes,
mais il a même peut-être
fait ça pour des bonnes raisons.
Et il s'est même dit
peut-être que s'il était
libéré de cet écharpe
dans la chair,
il pourrait même
mieux servir
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Mais,
nous avons au chapitre 12,
donc au verset 9
que nous avons lu,
qu'est-ce que le Seigneur
lui répond ?
Et donc, c'est Paul
qui le rapporte aux frères
pour les édifier là-dessus.
Il m'a dit
« Ma grâce te suffit,
car ma puissance
s'accomplit dans la faiblesse. »
Est-ce que le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
craignait que Paul
soit moins productif
dans son ministère
à cause de cette faiblesse ?
Non.
En fait,
la faiblesse de Paul
faisait partie du plan
parfait de Christ
pour montrer sa force,
pour montrer sa puissance.
Et ici,
nous devons voir
que Paul
est un merveilleux
exemple pour nous.
Est-ce que Paul
était accablé
par son infériorité ?
Est-ce que Paul
essayait
de cacher
cette faiblesse
lorsque les gens
allaient peut-être
découvrir
qu'il n'était pas
si apostolique,
on peut dire comme ça ?
Est-ce que
cet écharpe dans la chair
pouvait faire un moment
que les gens
ne veulent plus de lui ?
Ou que cet écharpe
dans la chair
va faire un moment
que les gens
vont même se dire
un moment,
mais c'est lui
qui est apôtre
et qui agit
comme ça ?
Il n'y a rien
qui garantisse
que rien de tout cela
pourrait arriver.
Mais comme nous l'avons vu
dans Proverbe 29,
verset 25,
voilà la voie
que Paul a choisie.
Paul a choisi
la voie
de la confiance en Dieu
plutôt que de la peur.
Voilà la réponse.
Lorsqu'il a prié
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
de lui enlever
cet écharpe dans la chair,
le Seigneur lui a dit
« Ma grâce te suffit
car ma puissance
s'accomplit dans la faiblesse. »
Quelle est la réponse
de Paul ?
C'est pourquoi
je me glorifierai
bien plus volontiers
de mes faiblesses
afin que la puissance
de Christ repose sur moi.
Il dit
« Je me contente donc
à cause de Christ
des faiblesses,
des insultes,
des tribulations,
des persécutions
et des calamités.
Car lorsque je suis faible,
c'est alors que je suis fort.
Donc,
comment Paul est fort
lorsqu'il est faible ?
Pourquoi Paul va considérer
qu'il est fort
lorsqu'il est faible ?
C'est parce que
le but de sa vie
était de manifester
la gloire de Christ.
Le but de sa vie
n'était pas
qu'il se sente mieux
dans ce qu'il pouvait être.
Le but de sa vie
était de manifester
la gloire de Christ.
Et si la faiblesse
qu'il avait dans sa vie
lui permettait
de manifester,
de parvenir
à glorifier le Christ,
elle ne faisait
que renforcer
sa détermination
à servir Dieu.
Jean,
1 Jean 4,
verset 18,
l'amour,
l'amour parfait
bannit la crainte.
notre façon à nous,
quelque chose
qui est meilleur
que l'estime de soi,
vous voyez,
en tant que tel,
l'estime de soi
ne peut rien apporter.
Dans des éclairs,
dans des moments
de notre vie,
lorsque nous avons
peut-être obtenu
une promotion au travail,
lorsque nous avons
une bonne famille,
notre estime de soi
peut nous amener
à considérer
que nous sommes bons.
j'ai réussi au travail,
on m'a augmenté
parce que je suis bon.
Je suis en train
de réussir dans ma vie,
j'élève mes enfants
comme il le faut
parce que je suis bon.
Mais nous voyons
à un moment
que cette estime de soi
peut se briser
du jour au lendemain.
C'est une idole.
Et ce que Dieu fait
avec les idoles,
c'est qu'à un moment,
Dieu nous montre
que l'idole
est incapable
de nous amener
ce qu'elle était censée
nous donner,
cette paix,
cette joie.
L'apôtre Paul,
lorsqu'il est en train
d'exprimer
dans 2 Corinthiens 12
et nous avons lu le passage
« L'amour parfait
banni la crainte »
dans 1 Jean 4, 18,
Paul savait
qu'il était aimé de Jésus.
Voilà quelque chose
qui est meilleur
que l'estime de soi.
C'est de savoir
que nous sommes aimés
de Jésus.
Comme nous sommes aimés
de Jésus,
nous devons avoir
cette attitude
de lui faire entièrement
confiance.
Si le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
avait jugé préférable
de ne pas délivrer
l'apôtre Paul
de cet écharpe
dans la chair,
il ne s'en contenterait pas.
C'est-à-dire,
Paul ne va pas juste
se contenter
que Christ
ne le délivre pas.
Au contraire,
il va même se glorifier
de cette faiblesse.
La réponse de la Bible
au piège
de l'estime de soi
est la confiance.
Pas la confiance
en l'homme,
la confiance en l'éternel.
Ayant confiance
en Jésus-Christ,
sachant
ce qu'il a prévu
pour nous,
utilisant
ce que Christ
a prévu pour nous,
c'est d'utiliser
notre vie
pour manifester
sa gloire
et sa bonté.
C'est très important
de voir que Dieu
utilise nos vies,
Dieu utilise nos faiblesses
pour manifester
sa gloire,
mais pas seulement
sa bonté.
Une chose
qui m'a marqué
quand je prépare
les prédications
des équels,
c'est cet aspect
de la sainteté
de Dieu,
mais aussi
la grande miséricorde
de Dieu.
Ayez confiance
en l'œuvre
de Christ,
quelle que soit
la manière
dont il choisit
de le faire.
C'est ainsi
que vous échapperez
à la crainte
des hommes.
Ce n'est pas
un aveuglement
superficiel
où nous sommes
dans un aveuglement
superficiel
de notre faiblesse,
mais comme Paul,
nous sommes en train
de nous glorifier
de notre faiblesse,
nous mettons en avant
notre faiblesse.
Si vous trouvez
un pasteur
qui est en train
de prêcher
et qui est en train
de vanter
toutes les qualités
qu'il a dans sa vie,
fuez cette personne.
Mais si vous trouvez
un pasteur
qui est en train
de vous rappeler
un moment
qu'il est un pécheur
et qu'il a chaque jour
besoin de la grâce
de Christ
et qu'il n'est pas
en train de se présenter
comme étant quelqu'un
super spirituel
qui est au-dessus
d'une autre compréhension
de Dieu,
si vous trouvez
quelqu'un
qui est en train
de se glorifier
de ses faiblesses,
alors sachez
prier pour lui
et sachez aussi
poursuivre le chemin
avec lui.
Enfin,
pour finir,
on va aborder
ces trois types
de luttes
contre l'image
de soi,
on peut dire.
Pour le reste
de notre temps
ensemble ce soir,
je vais aborder
trois façons
différentes
de lutter
contre le sentiment
d'infériorité,
on va même dire
ce sentiment
de supériorité
et de leur appliquer
cette vérité.
Mais là,
avant de continuer,
je ne sais pas,
est-ce que vous avez
des questions
jusque-là ?
Pardon ?
Vous parlez de
des gens
qui guettent.
Le principe,
ce principe,
c'est de considérer
un moment que
quand on met en avant
l'estime de soi,
c'est qu'on est meilleur
que les autres.
On a un potentiel
et quand on a ce potentiel,
on doit s'assurer
un moment qu'il n'y a
rien qui nous empêche
d'accomplir ce potentiel.
Donc,
comment on va dire,
par exemple,
un collègue
qui,
par exemple,
si je dois passer
un entretien,
cette estime de soi,
c'est-à-dire tordue
au niveau des églises,
on va considérer
l'autre candidat
comme une menace
potentielle à moi.
Si j'ai trouvé
une entreprise
que j'aime beaucoup,
je vois tous les avantages
et j'estime
que je dois avoir
cette place,
je trouverai
les autres candidats
comme étant une nuisance.
Ce n'est pas biblique.
Ensuite,
même au niveau
de l'église,
par exemple,
on va considérer
à un moment
que quelqu'un
qui m'apporte
des problèmes,
quelqu'un qui me,
on va dire,
qui me vole ma paix
est quelqu'un
qui est en train
de nuire
à mon épanouissement
personnel.
Ce n'est pas biblique
aussi.
Donc,
c'est un peu
dans ce sens-là.
Mais c'est quelque chose
qui est très répandu
aujourd'hui dans les églises
où ils mettent beaucoup
en avant le développement
personnel.
Ou à un moment,
on va,
voilà,
cette emprise
que toi,
tu es meilleur
et que les autres
sont des parasites
souvent autour de toi.
Il faut que tu trouves
quelqu'un qui est meilleur,
qui partage les mêmes convictions
de développer le potentiel
et là,
vous pouvez aller ensemble.
Bien sûr,
là,
comme ça,
c'est encore
un autre développement
monde d'orgueil.
Une autre question.
Oui,
il peut y avoir de ça aussi.
Il peut aussi y avoir de ça.
Mais quand nous regardons
l'exemple biblique,
l'exemple biblique
est beaucoup plus différent
de ça.
L'exemple biblique,
à un moment,
c'est que nous sommes appelés
à être des bénédictions,
quel que soit le cœur
des personnes.
Et donc,
à un moment,
je ne vais pas quitter
une église,
à un moment,
parce que j'ai trouvé
des gens difficiles.
Je vais quitter une église
parce que la parole
n'est pas enseignée.
Mais je ne vais pas quitter
une église parce que
je vais trouver des gens
difficiles qui ne me disent
pas bonjour,
qui sont impolis,
qui sont ingrats,
qui ne prennent pas
de mes nouvelles.
Ce n'est pas une justification.
Ils peuvent être toxiques
d'une certaine façon
parce qu'ils n'appliquent
pas les principes bibliques.
Mais ça ne va pas justifier
mon attitude.
Là,
mon attitude sera plutôt
de prier
et de manifester l'évangile.
Comment on fait
la démarcation
entre
ne pas chasser
les personnes toxiques
en s'aliment,
mais à la fois
ne pas s'asseoir
sur le banc
des moqueurs
du psaume 1 ?
C'est quoi la différence
entre les deux concepts ?
La différence,
déjà,
c'est la façon
dont nous plaçons.
C'est-à-dire,
si nous sommes
dans la solution
estime de soi,
on va déjà échouer.
Si nous sommes
dans la solution
de Christ,
la solution
c'est quoi ?
C'est qu'à un moment,
si quelqu'un m'a offensé,
77 fois 7,
au niveau du pardon.
Et donc,
déjà là,
on comprend un moment
que sur ce principe,
déjà,
je suis appelé
à un moment
à pardonner,
à restaurer
les personnes.
Si maintenant,
je suis dans une situation
où ces personnes
peuvent être
une occasion de chute
pour moi,
là,
je peux pardonner
et là,
je dois aussi
prendre mes distances.
Donc,
par exemple,
si j'ai des amis
non-croyants
et que j'ai l'intention
de les évangéliser,
je me dois de leur
renoncer l'évangile.
Mais si je vois
qu'en leur compagnie,
ça peut être une occasion
de chute par rapport
à certains aspects,
alors je devrais
prendre mes distances.
Donc,
c'est toujours un peu ce...
C'est-à-dire,
il faut réussir
à prendre ses distances,
mais il faut aussi
réussir à garder
un lien avec ces personnes
pour avoir la capacité
de continuer
à leur renoncer
de l'évangile.
Et la chose
qui est très importante
là-dessus,
c'est qu'ils sachent
toujours les convictions
que nous portons.
Il est très facile
de tomber dans un péché
si nous n'avons pas
montré de la fermeté
vis-à-vis de ce péché.
Si à un moment,
je ne vais pas signaler
que j'ai un problème
avec tel péché,
dès qu'on va me le proposer
un moment,
par crainte de l'homme,
je suis capable
de tomber dans ce péché
parce que j'ai peur
de l'homme.
Mais quand je suis,
par exemple,
le commérage au travail,
si par exemple,
dès les instants
où quelqu'un vient
se plaindre
d'un autre collègue,
je lui dis à un moment
que je ne veux pas
entendre ces choses,
ce qui va se passer,
c'est que dès que je viendrai,
lorsqu'ils sont en train
de discuter,
de critiquer un collègue,
ils vont se taire
parce qu'ils savent
à un moment
que je ne porte pas
ce genre de choses-là.
Mais si je n'ai pas fait
par crainte de l'homme
parce que c'est peut-être
mon responsable,
donc quand il vient
se plaindre,
je me tais parce que
j'ai peur des représailles,
ce qui va se passer,
c'est que je vais cautionner
ce péché-là.
Donc c'est important
à un moment
de poser des barrières,
mais cette même personne
qui vient se plaindre,
c'est aussi une personne
à qui je dois l'évangile.
Donc chaque fois,
c'est une question d'équilibre
où on doit se préserver
du péché,
mais on doit aussi garder
la possibilité
d'annoncer l'évangile
à ces personnes.
Alors là,
j'aurais bien voulu,
j'ai même oublié en fait,
parce qu'il y aurait eu
un tableau qui...
Donc là,
sur ce dernier point,
trois types de lutte
contre l'image de soi
qui sont très importantes
à voir.
Alors,
Lou Priolo,
si vous voulez,
là j'ai le titre en français,
peut-être en anglais,
je ne sais pas
ce que ça donne,
dans son livre
« Images de soi »,
donc ça peut être
« self-estime »,
Lou Priolo décrit
trois façons de lutter
contre une mauvaise image de soi.
Alors,
lorsque nous avons,
il y a trois,
il y a trois façons
de lutter
contre une mauvaise image de soi,
parce qu'il y a
trois perceptions,
il y a trois perceptions
de l'image de soi
que nous avons.
La première,
il y a des perceptions
erronées de soi.
Donc ça,
vous pouvez même déjà
réfléchir à ça.
Une première perception
erronée,
donc ça veut dire
qu'à un moment,
on croit percevoir
une réalité qui n'est pas vraie,
c'est-à-dire,
on a l'impression.
Et quelle est l'une
des choses les plus communes ?
Personne ne m'aime.
Ça, j'ai déjà entendu
ça tellement de fois.
Personne ne m'aime,
personne ne prend
considération de moi,
personne ne fait
attention à moi.
Ou ça peut être
« personne ne m'aime,
je ne peux jamais
rien faire de bien ».
C'est là que nous avons
besoin d'un changement
de perception.
Nous avons besoin
de conformer notre vision
de la réalité
aux Écritures.
Parce que si je suis honnête
vis-à-vis du Seigneur,
quand je suis en train
de dire « personne ne m'aime »,
je vais remarquer quand même
qu'il y a des gens
qui m'aiment.
Mais c'est parce que souvent,
je ne vais pas prêter
attention à cet amour
parce que je ne le trouve
pas intéressant pour moi,
alors que ces personnes
manifestent de l'amour.
Il y a des personnes
qui m'aiment.
Mais souvent,
nous entendons beaucoup ça.
Donc ça,
c'est déjà une perception
erronée.
Même le fait de dire
« moi, je ne peux rien
faire de bien dans ma vie »,
ça, c'est déjà
une perception erronée.
Parce que ce que Dieu
t'a donné de faire,
avec les capacités
que tu as,
c'est que tu peux faire
quelque chose dans ta vie.
Donc,
quand nous avons
ce genre de perception,
vous pouvez faire un examen,
vous allez déjà voir
qui vous est déjà arrivé
dans votre vie,
de pouvoir vous dire
ce genre de choses.
Moi, dans cette semaine,
il y avait un autre aspect
où je me suis dit
ce genre de choses,
comme ça.
Et pendant que j'étais
en train de préparer
le cours,
je réalisais, oui.
Mais ce que nous avons
besoin là-dessus,
c'est de conformer
notre vision
de la réalité
aux Écritures.
une deuxième perception,
c'est lorsque nos perceptions
sont exactes,
mais que nous jugeons
quelque chose d'anormal
qui ne l'est pas vraiment.
Nous avons une perception exacte,
mais c'est une perception,
donc comme je dis,
perception appropriée,
mais qui n'est pas pécheresse.
Par exemple,
quelqu'un va dire
« je suis trop petit ».
Ce n'est pas un péché
que tu sois trop petit,
tu es trop petit.
Je ne suis pas très intelligent.
Dans ces cas-là aussi,
il nous faut encore mieux
nous conformer
nos valeurs aux Écritures.
On avait souvent la blague
de dire à un moment
que si tu as un problème,
que tu es trop petit,
il y avait certains
qui le prenaient vraiment
à cœur,
ils disaient à un moment
« je suis trop petit ».
Pendant qu'on distribuait
les tailles au ciel,
je n'étais pas là.
Mais ce n'est pas une question.
Ça, c'est une hérésie biblique.
La vérité,
c'est que Dieu,
dans sa souveraineté,
a permis que tu sois trop petit.
Là,
conformant nos valeurs,
donc j'ai parlé tout à l'heure,
dans le premier aspect,
on a une perception inappropriée.
C'est-à-dire,
on va dire
« personne ne m'aime ».
Et pourtant,
on a nos parents
qui nous aiment,
on a des amis,
on a des frères,
mais on va dire
« personne ne m'aime »
parce qu'on a peut-être
d'autres sources
qu'on aurait voulu d'amour
qui ne le manifestent pas
et on trouve
que personne ne nous aime.
et même quand nous le disons,
nous sommes en train
de nier le fait
que Christ nous aime.
Donc là,
il faut conformer
notre vision
de la réalité aux Écritures.
Dans le deuxième aspect,
lorsqu'on va se trouver
trop petit,
pas assez intelligent,
dans tous ces cas,
il faut que nous conformions
nos valeurs
aux Écritures.
Et troisièmement,
lorsque notre perception
et nos valeurs
sont exactes,
donc ça peut arriver maintenant,
on a une perception appropriée,
on a des valeurs
qui sont appropriées
et on va arriver
à une conclusion,
par exemple,
je suis paresseux,
je suis colérique.
Qu'est-ce que nous devons faire
dans ce cas ?
Dans ce cas,
ce qui doit être
conforme aux Écritures,
ce ne sont pas
nos perceptions,
notre valeur,
mais ça doit être
notre comportement,
ça doit être notre cœur.
Donc là,
nous sommes maintenant
dans une perception
qui est vraie.
Nous savons
que nous sommes paresseux.
Mais qu'est-ce que je fais
par rapport à ce que dit
la parole de Dieu
par rapport à ma paresse ?
Donc là,
vous pouvez réfléchir
même plus tard,
après cette étude,
vous pouvez aussi réfléchir
à ces aspects un peu
de la perception inappropriée
ou appropriée
qui n'est pas pécheresse,
perception appropriée,
pécheresse,
toutes ces choses-là.
Je vous ai donné
quelques-uns
de ces aspects
pour commencer,
mais voilà,
réfléchissez à ça
et vous pouvez voir
ces aspects
où vous pouvez vous considérer
inférieur,
vous pouvez vous sentir
rejeté ou inférieur
aux autres.
Mais ce que je voudrais faire
pour finir ce soir,
nous allons examiner
les trois catégories
une à une,
une par une,
et nous allons essayer
d'appliquer
l'idée principale
de la première partie
du cours.
Qu'est-ce que nous avons dit
dans la première partie
du cours
en conclusion ici ?
Nous échappons au piège
de la peur des hommes
en faisant confiance
au dessein de Dieu
pour nous.
Donc,
lorsque nous avons
des perceptions inexactes,
lorsque,
je reprends encore
l'exemple que j'ai pris,
on va penser
qu'on n'est pas aimé,
telle ou telle chose,
la première catégorie
est celle
où on se sent inférieur
simplement parce que
ce que l'on ressent
n'est pas vrai.
En fait,
bien souvent,
on sait que ce n'est pas vrai.
On va prendre l'exemple
de quelqu'un
qui dit
personne ne m'aime.
On peut imaginer
qu'au niveau propositionnel,
même la personne
qui dit à un moment
personne ne m'aime,
il sait que ce n'est pas vrai.
Mais même quand il sait
que ce n'est pas vrai,
il est en train
de ressentir
quand même ce sentiment.
Et le simple fait
de le savoir
ne change rien
à ce sentiment-là.
Donc,
même si on va
savoir à un moment
que je suis
conscient à un moment
que je suis en train
de me mentir
moi-même,
je me dis à un moment
personne ne m'aime.
Je sais que je suis
en train de me mentir
moi-même.
Mais un moment,
c'est tellement fort
que même quand je sais
que je suis en train
de me mentir moi-même,
cette perception
est en train
d'étouffer ma vie.
Je suis vraiment
en train de croire
que personne ne fait
attention à moi.
Voilà.
Qu'est-ce que nous devons
faire par rapport
à cette perception
inappropriée ?
Tout d'abord,
nous devons nous rappeler
la doctrine biblique
du péché.
Qu'est-ce que cette
doctrine nous apprend ?
Elle nous apprend que
même en tant que pécheur
racheté,
nous sommes souillés
par le péché
et que le péché
déforme notre perception
de la réalité.
Nous ne devons pas
donc nous étonner
si nos sentiments
et même nos sens
nous révèlent souvent
des choses fausses.
On va souvent...
Combien de fois
on a eu l'impression
que deux personnes
qui sont en train
de discuter
sont en train
de se moquer de nous
alors qu'elles ont peut-être
tourné la tête vers nous
et on se dit
« Oh là, j'ai le sentiment
qui se moque de moi. »
Ce sont des perceptions
qui nous révèlent
des choses fausses.
Mais nous devons penser
à ce que la parole de Dieu
nous dit dans Proverbe 28,
verset 26.
« Celui qui se confie
en son cœur
est un insensé,
mais celui qui marche
avec sagesse
sera sauvé. »
Être sage
signifie croire
en la parole de Dieu
comme seule mesure
fiable de la réalité.
Aujourd'hui,
on va dire un moment
« Suis les voies
de ton cœur. »
Ne suivez surtout pas
les voies de votre cœur.
Si vous êtes croyant
et que vous êtes en train
de dire un moment
« Il faut que je suive
les voies de mon cœur. »
Les voies du cœur
sont tortueuses.
nous amènent
à cette perception
déformée de la réalité.
Mais nous avons besoin
au contraire
que la parole de Dieu
nous permette
de marcher
avec sagesse.
Donc,
la première chose,
c'est de nous rappeler
un moment
que la parole de Dieu
doit être la seule
mesure fiable
de la réalité
quand il faut lutter
contre les perceptions
inappropriées.
Un deuxième aspect,
c'est de nous discipliner
à méditer
sur ce que nous savons
être la vérité.
Un des plus beaux passages
de la Bible
à ce sujet,
c'est Philippiens 4,
verset 8.
« Aux restes frères,
que tout ce qui est vrai,
tout ce qui est honorable,
tout ce qui est juste,
tout ce qui est pur,
tout ce qui est aimable,
tout ce qui mérite
l'approbation,
ce qui est vertueux
et digne de louanges
soit l'objet
de vos pensées. »
Ou alors,
2 Corinthiens 10,
verset 5,
« Rendez toute pensée captive
à l'obéissance à Christ. »
Parfois,
quand on sait
que quelque chose
n'est pas vrai,
même si cela
semble tout à fait vrai,
il faut prendre conscience
de sa vie intérieure
et se dire
ce qui est vrai.
Comment nous pouvons
nous dire
ce qui est vrai ?
Comment nous pouvons
le faire ?
Et c'est là
où c'est intéressant
parce que notre frère,
on ne s'est pas concerté
avec Pierre, lui,
mais l'esprit
l'a conduit aussi
sur ce passage.
Nous devons nous rappeler
de la parole de Dieu.
Pour reprendre
une question populaire,
donc je vais reprendre,
c'est une question
que le pasteur
Martin Lloyd-Jones
avait posée.
Il avait dit à un moment,
est-ce que vous avez réalisé
que la plupart
de vos malheurs
viennent du fait
que vous vous écoutez
au lieu de vous parler ?
Vous vous écoutez
en vous-même,
mais vous n'êtes pas
en train de vous parler.
Et il va faire référence
au psaume,
si vous avez suivi,
42,
oui,
43.
Donc,
Martin Lloyd-Jones
fait référence
au psaume 42
où nous écoutons
cette conversation
entre le psalmiste
et lui-même.
« Pourquoi es-tu abattu
mon âme
et pourquoi es-tu agité
au-dedans de moi ?
Espère en Dieu,
car je le louerai encore.
Lui, mon salut
et mon Dieu. »
Revenons donc
à ce que Lloyd-Jones
dit à ce sujet.
Il dit,
« Tu dois dire à ton âme
pourquoi es-tu abattu,
pourquoi t'inquiètes-tu ?
Tu dois te retourner
contre toi-même,
tu dois te réprimander,
tu dois te condamner,
t'exhorter
et te dire
« Espère en Dieu »
au lieu de marmonner
avec cette tristesse
et ce découragement.
Ensuite,
tu dois te rappeler,
tu dois te rappeler Dieu,
tu dois te rappeler Dieu
dans ton esprit.
Donc là aussi,
encore notre frère
nous a parlé
de cet aspect du souvenir.
Tu dois te rappeler Dieu,
tu dois te rappeler
qui est Dieu,
ce qu'il est
et qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
et ce qu'il s'est engagé
à faire pour toi.
Puis,
après que tu aies fait cela,
termine
sur cette note solennelle.
toi-même,
pose-toi un défi,
tu défies les autres,
tu défies le diable,
tu défies le monde entier
et tu dis avec le psalmiste
« Je le louerai encore. »
Donc,
dans cette première catégorie
de la perception inappropriée,
comment nous faisons
pour lutter
contre cette perception
inappropriée
qui déforme la vérité
et la réalité de la vie ?
Dans cette première catégorie,
nous faisons confiance à Dieu
en faisant confiance
à sa parole.
La parole de Dieu
est plus fiable
que notre propre raisonnement,
elle est plus fiable
que notre propre expérience,
que nos propres sentiments,
elle est plus fiable
que notre propre perception.
Si vous avez
des perceptions erronées
dans cette première catégorie,
vous pouvez noter
à côté de ce que la Bible dit,
ouais,
je veux dire
ce que j'avais dit,
vous pouvez noter à côté
ce que la Bible dit
en sens contraire
si vous avez ces perceptions erronées
et vous mémorisez ces passages,
ce n'est pas
du développement personnel.
Nous voyons
que c'est ce que le psalmiste
applique.
Il rappelle à son âme
ce que dit
la parole de l'Éternel.
Nous devons rappeler
à notre âme
ce que dit
la parole de l'Éternel.
Et nous devons
mémoriser ces passages.
Comme le dit
le psaume 15,
celui qui marche
dans l'intégrité,
qui pratique la justice
et qui dit la vérité
dans son cœur,
celui qui fait
ces choses,
quelle est la conclusion
du psaume 15,
ne sera jamais ébranlée.
Non pas parce que
nous avons placé
notre confiance
en nous-mêmes,
en nos capacités,
mais parce que
nous croyons
que la parole de Dieu
est vraie.
Et donc,
nous luttons
contre cette fausse perception
de la réalité
de ce que nous sommes
parce que nous rappelons
à la réalité,
nous rappelons au monde,
au diable,
ce que Dieu
a dit de nous.
Le deuxième point,
quand nous avons
des perceptions appropriées
mais qui ne sont pas
pécheresses,
par exemple,
on va considérer
« je suis trop petit,
je suis ceci, cela »,
alors que ce n'est pas
un péché en soi-même,
mais c'est plutôt
des éléments.
Quand nous faisons face
à des perceptions précises
qui ne sont pas pécheresses,
donc,
en abordant
cette deuxième catégorie,
nous allons nous poser
aussi des questions.
dans bien des aspects
où le monde
va dire que nous luttons
contre l'estime de soi
et où la Bible
dirait que nous luttons
contre la peur de l'homme,
beaucoup
de ces aspects
sont liés
à des perceptions
de nous-mêmes
qui sont justes
mais qui sont
non pécheresses.
Nous n'avons rien fait de mal,
tu n'as rien fait de mal
pour être petit
mais tu te sens
tout de même inférieur.
Je crois qu'il faut
que je recherche
un autre exemple
que petit.
nous n'avons rien
fait de mal
mais nous nous sentons
de même inférieur.
Nous pouvons même
examiner dans notre vie
il y a des choses
je n'ai rien fait de mal
mais ces choses
sont dans ma vie
et je suis dans le regret,
je suis dans une perception
qui m'affecte.
Peut-être
nous sommes en train
de convoiter
les compétences
que Dieu a données
à un autre frère
ou à une autre sœur
ou que nous sommes en train
de mépriser
un aspect de la façon
dont Dieu nous a créés.
le danger ici
c'est que
même si notre perception
n'est pas pécheresse
notre réaction
à cette perception
peut devenir pécheresse
parce que
lorsque nous sommes en train
de nous considérer petit
nous sommes en train
de placer une échelle
de valeur
avec quelqu'un d'autre
que nous pouvons trouver grand
nous sommes en train
de rentrer dans
un aspect de convoitise
de mécontentement
dans beaucoup de cas
j'ai pris l'aspect
de petit
parce que c'est souvent
l'image corporelle
qui va souvent rentrer
dans cette catégorie
et qu'est-ce que nous
pouvons faire
de ces perceptions
je vous avais dit
là où nous avons
besoin d'un changement
nous avons besoin
dans le premier aspect
pour lutter
contre la perception
inappropriée
c'est un changement
de vision
ce n'est plus ma vision
à moi
la vision des gens
c'est la vision biblique
de ce que Dieu dit
de moi
maintenant quand je dois
lutter contre la perception
appropriée
mais qui n'est pas pécheresse
c'est un changement
de valeur
donc pour la première catégorie
j'ai dit que
notre doctrine clé
c'était celle du péché
en tant que pécheur
nous ne devrions pas
être surpris
lorsque nos perceptions
sont faussées
mais pour la seconde catégorie
notre doctrine
notre doctrine clé
est la justification
la doctrine selon laquelle
Dieu a déclaré
les chrétiens justes
non pas à cause
de leurs actions
mais uniquement
par sa grâce
par la foi
en tant que chrétien
vous êtes en règle
devant Dieu
sur tous les points
importants de votre vie
Romains 3 verset 23
nous dit
car tous sont péchés
et sont privés
de la gloire de Dieu
et ils sont gratuitement
justifiés par sa grâce
pourquoi c'est si important
pour nous
parce que beaucoup
de choses de ce genre
dans ces aspects
dont nous avons parlé
beaucoup de choses
de ce genre
nous donnent le sentiment
de ne pas être à la hauteur
on va convoiter
ce que nous voyons
de bon chez les autres
et nous allons à un moment
considérer que nous ne sommes
pas à la hauteur
nous ne sommes pas dignes
nous ne sommes même pas dignes
d'être aimés ou autres
mais Dieu
nous a rendus
suffisamment bons
par la foi en Jésus
c'est la seule déclaration
qui doit compter
c'est là on parle
d'un changement de valeur
ma valeur ne se trouve pas
dans mes capacités
ma valeur se trouve
dans la façon dont Christ
aujourd'hui me rend juste
alors qu'est-ce que nous
devons faire
lorsque nous nous faisons
face à une perception
qui nous amène
à une perception appropriée
mais qui n'est pas pécheresse
pardon
la première chose
c'est de faire confiance
à la sagesse de Dieu
faisons confiance
dans les faiblesses
qu'il nous a données
tout comme Paul
qui a appris
à se contenter
de ses faiblesses
Dieu
nous a créé
pour un but
et toutes nos faiblesses
qu'elles soient morales
comme physiques
sont sous
le contrôle bienveillant
de Dieu
est-ce que nous pouvons
lui faire confiance
est-ce que
tu es capable
de faire confiance
à Dieu
par rapport au handicap
que tu constates
dans ta vie
par rapport aux compétences
peu enviables
par rapport à ton corps
est-ce que tu peux
lui faire confiance
si tu lui fais confiance
sache que Dieu
va honorer
cette confiance
rappelons-nous
que son dessein
pour notre vie
est plus grand
que ce que
nous pouvons accomplir
plus grand que
alors
excusez-moi
sur la phrase
que j'avais dit
rappelons-nous
que le dessein
de notre Dieu
pour notre vie
est plus grand
que ce que
nous pouvons accomplir
plus grand
que ce que
nous pouvons aimer
plus grand
qu'un quelconque bonheur
Dieu
a refait
son image
en nous
donc nous aussi
nous pouvons en dire
comme Paul
je me glorifierai
bien plus volontiers
de mes faiblesses
afin que la puissance
de Christ repose sur moi
ou encore
dans 2 Corinthiens
au chapitre 3
nous tous
qui le visage
découvert
contemplant la gloire
du Seigneur
nous sommes transformés
en la même image
de plus en plus
glorieux
c'est ce que
Dieu est en train de faire
Dieu a fait
c'est ce que
Dieu est en train de faire
il n'y a rien
qui va l'arrêter
ni ta faiblesse
ni ton complexe
d'infériorité
de supériorité
ni le complexe
de quelqu'un d'autre
il n'y a rien
qui pourra arrêter
l'œuvre de Dieu
dans ta vie
la deuxième chose
pour lutter
contre cette perception
on va prendre encore
on va prendre
quelques 10 minutes
pour finir
la deuxième chose
pour lutter
contre ce deuxième aspect
de perception
c'est en grande partie
pour cette raison
que nous devons résister
à la tentation
de penser
que nous sommes bien
en nous comparant
aux autres
je ne suis pas bien
parce que
mon je ne suis pas bien
n'est pas aussi bon
que celui d'un tel
alors c'est un peu
difficile à comprendre
comme ça
mais dans la comparaison
on peut lire
2 Corinthiens 10
verset 12
c'est Paul
qui est en train
de parler
je vais vous lire
parce que
ça va vous aider
à comprendre
dans 2 Corinthiens 10
verset 12
il dit
nous n'osons pas
nous égaler
ou nous comparer
à quelqu'un
de ceux
qui se recommandent
eux-mêmes
mais en se mesurant
à leur propre mesure
et en se comparant
à eux-mêmes
ils manquent
d'intelligence
pour nous
nous ne voulons pas
nous glorifier
hors de toute mesure
nous prendrons au contraire
pour mesure
les limites du partage
que Dieu nous a assigné
de manière
à nous faire venir
aussi jusqu'à vous
donc il y a cet aspect
mais en se mesurant
à leur propre mesure
et en se comparant
à eux-mêmes
ils manquent
d'intelligence
pourquoi Dieu
ne nous a-t-il pas
donné les dons
et les compétences
de notre voisin
ça on va toujours
l'ignorer
mais Dieu l'a fait
pour une raison
et nous pouvons
lui faire confiance
la comparaison
est une forme
d'orgueil
la comparaison
signifie essentiellement
que nous savons
mieux que Dieu
la comparaison
c'est que nous
estimons à un moment
que Dieu
aurait dû faire
cette chose
de telle façon
pour sortir du piège
de la comparaison
il faut identifier
d'où vient
cette comparaison
dans notre coeur pécheur
d'où vient
ce désir
de nous comparer
et nous devons prier
et demander pardon
à Dieu
Seigneur pardonne-moi
de penser que je ne suis pas
assez bien pour toi
à moins que je ne sois
comme mon frère Miguel
par exemple
car je sais
que tu m'as déclaré
assez bien pour toi
en Jésus
c'est ça que nous
devons comprendre
nous ne devons pas
être dans une échelle
de comparaison
avec les autres
nous devons être
dans une échelle
de compréhension
que Dieu
nous a déclaré
assez bien
en Christ
ou encore souvent
notre aspect
de prière
aussi ça doit être
de demander pardon
à Dieu
de ne pas nous contenter
du rôle
pour lequel
il nous a créé
de demander pardon
à Dieu
chaque fois que nous avons
du mal
à lui faire confiance
dans sa sagesse
et son amour
et que nous sommes
en train de convoiter
ce qu'il a pu donner
à un autre
je suis en train
de convoiter
les qualités
que mon frère
Raja
peut avoir
le troisième point
sur cette perception
appropriée
qui n'est pas
pécheresse
nous avons
donc là
sur ce point
c'était de
nous séparer
de la comparaison
avec les autres
mais troisièmement
nous avons besoin
nous avons parfois
besoin de fortifier
notre conscience
Paul écrit
dans 1 Corinthiens 8
donc il parle
à un moment
qu'il y avait
cet aspect
où il y avait
des frères
qui avaient
la conscience
troublée
parce qu'il y en avait
d'autres
qui allaient manger
des viandes
sacrifiées aux idoles
toutes ces choses
parfois nous avons
l'impression
que certaines choses
sont mauvaises
même si la Bible
ne les qualifie pas
de mauvaises
c'est intéressant
et Paul prend en compte
ce genre de conscience
donc Paul parle
de ce genre de conscience
mais il ne qualifie pas
ce genre de confiance
de forte
il dit que les personnes
qui ont du mal
à accepter
que d'autres
puissent manger
des viandes
sacrifiées aux idoles
parce qu'elles sont
même déjà sanctifiées
par le croyant
par la prière du croyant
il va qualifier
ses consciences
de faibles
nous avons parfois
un sentiment
d'infériorité
parce que notre conscience
a besoin d'être éduquée
à l'époque de Paul
manger de la nourriture
sacrifiée aux idoles
n'était pas mal
c'est ce que Paul
va mettre en avant
de même pour nous
il peut arriver
un moment
qu'on ne va pas
avoir assez
de temps
pour nous recueillir
au quotidien
mais ça veut dire
que ce n'est pas mal
le plus important
pour nous
c'est de comprendre
un moment
que la puissance
de Dieu
s'accomplit
dans mes faiblesses
si au bout
de cette semaine
nous sommes vendredi
si je n'ai pas lu
la Bible
comme il fallait
si je n'ai pas prié
il faut que je me souvienne
que la puissance
de Dieu
s'accomplit
dans mes faiblesses
et voilà pourquoi
Christ
qu'est-ce que Christ a fait
il a parfaitement
accompli la loi
quand on dit
Christ a parfaitement
accompli la loi
c'est que chaque jour
que notre Dieu a fait
que Christ a passé
sur terre
dès qu'il a eu
la capacité
de pouvoir méditer
sur la parole
il l'a fait fidèlement
quels que soient
les troubles
même quand il ne se sentait
pas bien
il a médité la parole
et pourquoi il l'a fait
il l'a fait pour nous
pour qu'un jour
il puisse se présenter
devant le Père
et lorsque moi
je suis en train
de faillir dans ces choses
il va dire
à un moment
j'ai payé le prix
pour lui
pardonne-le
pardonne-lui
et restaure-le
donc voici
j'ai donc pris
trois façons
pour nous
d'échapper au piège
de la peur de l'homme
lorsque nous pouvons
nous sentir inférieurs
considérer
à un moment
que les valeurs
que nous portons
les qualités
que nous pouvons avoir
ne sont pas conformes
en est dans la comparaison
nous devons voir
que nos valeurs
doivent être conformes
aux écritures
et enfin
pour finir
avec les perceptions
exactes
qui sont pécheresses
enfin pour conclure
sur ces trois aspects
qu'est-ce que nous devons
faire des perceptions
d'infériorité
qui sont fondées
et qui sont un péché
donc j'ai pris l'exemple
quand je vais dire
à un moment
je suis paresseux
c'est une vérité
par exemple
je vais à un moment
je peux être
quelqu'un
qui est tellement porté
dans la comparaison
avec les autres
que ça me rend malade
je peux lutter
contre la luxure
ça fait des années
je lutte contre la luxure
je lutte contre l'avidité
je lutte contre la paresse
je lutte contre l'amertume
je lutte contre la colère
qu'est-ce que je dois faire
de l'infériorité
que je ressens
à cause de ces choses
je vais être
beaucoup plus bref
parce que ce n'est pas
le sujet
ce n'est pas
l'importance
n'est pas de traiter
un peu ces choses-là
mais je vais donner
quelques points
là-dessus
pour nous éclairer
sur cette perception
appropriée
lorsqu'elle est pécheresse
tout d'abord
la doctrine clé
donc on a parlé
de plusieurs doctrines
il y avait la doctrine
du péché avant
de la justification
de nous voir justifiés
par Christ
dans le deuxième aspect
dans ce troisième aspect
la doctrine clé
c'est la sanctification
lorsque Dieu
nous a sauvés
il a décidé
dans sa mystérieuse providence
de ne pas nous rendre
parfaits immédiatement
il nous a pas
dès que tu as été convert
tu n'as pas été délivré
de toutes les faiblesses
de tout ce que tu pouvais porter
au lieu de cela
il t'a promis un jour
que tu serais parfait
que tu serais glorifié
et il t'a justifié
il t'a déclaré juste
mais c'est un processus
qui consiste à ressembler
davantage à Christ
chaque jour
de notre vie chrétienne
j'ai lu le passage
transformé de plus en plus
à l'image de Christ
c'est ce qu'on appelle
la sanctification
et souvent
c'est un processus
qui peut être lent
qui peut être douloureux
nous pouvons nous poser
la question
pourquoi Dieu
nous a-t-il
simplement pas
créé parfait
c'est-à-dire
après ma conversion
pourquoi je ne suis pas
devenu directement parfait
nous ne savons pas ça
nous pouvons spéculer
et notre spéculation
se concentre sur
l'objectif principal
pour nous
pourquoi Dieu fait ça
c'est pour nous montrer
qui il est
imaginons qu'avant
de devenir chrétien
on était en train
de lutter contre
une dépendance
et le jour où
nous sommes devenus
croyants
Dieu nous a enlevé ça
c'est incroyable
il le fait
il l'a même déjà
je pense que chacun
de nous peut témoigner
d'un péché
qui était dans sa vie
et après
quand Christ
est rentré dans sa vie
il a été délivré
de ce péché
est-ce que cela
met en valeur
la gloire de Christ
la valeur de la gloire
de Christ
oui
ça révèle la gloire
de sa puissance
mais d'un autre côté
supposons maintenant
dans notre vie
même après notre conversion
il y a des choses
contre lesquelles
nous luttons
il y a des choses
on ne s'est pas débarrassé
facilement
et ce sont des choses
qui nous affectent
c'est des choses
qui sont comme une écharpe
dans notre chair
et maintenant
chaque jour
de notre vie
chrétienne
on doit choisir
par la foi
et c'est cet aspect
où Dieu nous amène
on doit choisir
par la foi
que les promesses
de Dieu
sont meilleures
pour nous
que la chose
contre laquelle
nous luttons
et avec le temps
quand nous sommes
en train
de partir
dans ce sens
par rapport à ces choses
nous nous
croyons aux promesses
de Dieu
Dieu m'a promis
qu'il va me sanctifier
donc je sais
un moment
que ce péché
dans lequel je suis
je ne vais pas y rester
éternellement
un jour
peut-être même
déjà ici bas
je connaîtrai le repos
et je connaîtrai
le repos
dans l'éternité
donc un moment
Dieu nous amène
dans notre vie
chrétienne
un moment
il y aura une étape
de notre vie chrétienne
où nous allons
considérer que les promesses
de Dieu sont meilleures
pour nous
que celles
du péché
contre lequel nous luttons
et avec le temps
les désirs que nous
pouvons porter
vont nous amener
les désirs que nous portons
de plus en plus
vers Christ
vont nous amener
à lutter
contre cette dépendance
maintenant
Dieu a montré
sa puissance
dans notre vie
mais maintenant
il montre aussi
sa bonté
parce que notre vie
est un témoignage
vivant
que Dieu
est meilleur
et que
les promesses
de Dieu
sont meilleures
que notre péché
voilà
notre vie
est un témoignage
de la bonté de Dieu
notre vie témoigne
et vous pouvez juste
vous arrêter
depuis quand
vous êtes devenu chrétien
et là
je peux même encore
prendre l'exemple
j'ai rencontré
des chrétiens
qui vont dire
à un moment
je ne me sens pas
je ne crois pas
que Dieu travaille
ma sanctification
je ne me sens pas
sain
non
si tu t'arrêtes
si tu t'es converti
depuis trois ans
regarde le parcours
que tu as depuis trois ans
est-ce que ta vie
est la même
est-ce que tu as
tu n'as pas du tout
changé depuis trois ans
alors
lorsque nous nous sentons
inférieurs
parce que
nous avons
cette impression
de ne pas nous sanctifier
assez vite
nous devons faire
confiance à Dieu
ayons confiance
au rythme
de l'œuvre de Dieu
dans notre vie
ayons confiance
que Dieu
nous mènera
ayons confiance
que Dieu
est plus peiné
par notre péché
que nous
et pourtant
pour une raison
comme une autre
il n'a pas encore
fini de transformer
notre cœur
est-ce que
en quelque sorte
nous nous considérons
comme un chrétien
inférieur à cause
de notre péché
Dieu se réjouit
de notre sainteté
et Dieu promet
qu'il va utiliser
il va nous utiliser
dans le bon combat
de la foi
pour que nous devenions
saints
je vous donne la référence
si vous voulez lire
2 Timothée 2
verset 21
mais c'est pour rappeler
la Bible
ne nous parle pas
de hiérarchie
entre un bon chrétien
et un chrétien
qui est moins bon
chacun
nous sommes responsables
vous êtes responsables
de nos péchés
je veux dire un moment
dans ces aspects
nous sommes responsables
des péchés
que nous pouvons apporter
dans la vie des autres
mais nous avons
la responsabilité
de nous dépouiller
de notre vieil homme
et de revêture
l'homme nouveau
et je rappelle
ce qui est dit
dans la parole
créer à l'image de Dieu
dans une justice
et une sainteté
que produit la vérité
chaque jour
qui passe
dans la présence
de Dieu
Dieu est en train
de produire
la justice
et la sainteté
que produit la vérité
de sa parole
dans ta vie
même si tu as l'impression
que ce n'est pas le cas
donc
pourtant
même si nous avons
cette impression
de ne pas avancer
nous devons comprendre
que nous sommes
exactement là
où Dieu a voulu
que nous soyons
et nous devons
faire confiance à Dieu
et en conclusion
donc par rapport
au cours de ce soir
quelle est la réponse
de la Bible
à l'estime de soi
comme nous l'avons vu
la doctrine
je peux même appeler ça
la doctrine de l'estime
de soi
c'est une doctrine
qui est pleine de promesses
si vous allez
sur les réseaux sociaux
essayez de voir
toutes les promesses
qui sont rattachées
à l'estime de soi
tout ce que ça peut apporter
dans le coeur
d'un homme
mais si vous comprenez
votre valeur
intrinsèque
donc ça c'est
le
le principe
si vous comprenez
votre valeur
vous serez plus heureux
plus aimant
meilleur travailleur
plus maître de vous-même
moins colérique
plus satisfait
et la liste est longue
mais la Bible nous dit
à un moment
que c'est faux
le péché
nous souille
quel que soit
ce que nous pouvons
donner une image
parfaite
de personnes
qui ont l'estime
de soi
qui est à son apogée
qui est à son haut niveau
mais lorsque nous nous regardons
dans un miroir
lorsque nous vivons nos vies
nous voyons à un moment
que cette estime de soi
elle est zéro
mais la Bible nous dit
à un moment
les écritures nous suggèrent
quelque chose d'autre
la Bible nous dit
comment nous pouvons
être plus heureux
plus aimants
meilleurs travailleurs
plus maîtres de nous-mêmes
moins colériques
plus satisfaits
et ainsi de suite
voilà ce que Romain 12
verset 3 nous dit
je dis à chacun de vous
de ne pas avoir de lui-même
une trop haute opinion
l'estime de soi
c'est que tu as
une haute opinion de toi
pour réaliser ton potentiel
la Bible nous dit
n'ayez pas
une trop haute opinion de vous
mais revêtez-vous
de sentiments modestes
l'estime de soi
c'est pas vos
non
il ne faut pas se revêtir
de l'estime de soi
il faut se revêtir
de l'estime de Christ
découvrez la gloire de Dieu
apprenez à vous réjouir
du plan
qu'il a établi pour vous
dès l'aube des temps
et lorsque vous êtes en train
de réaliser
la grâce
de voir que Dieu
travaille fidèlement
au plan qu'il a établi
pour vous
vous allez comprendre
que ce plan
contribue à le faire connaître
vous allez comprendre
un moment
qu'il est faiblesse
pour lesquelles vous devez
vous glorifier
vous permettre
de mieux connaître Dieu
et alors
quelle est la conclusion
ayez confiance
et dites-vous un moment
le plan de Dieu
pour ma vie
est le meilleur
et si je suis en train
de rechercher d'abord
le royaume de Dieu
avant toute chose
alors
je ne vais pas être
dans la valeur de moi-même
qui est nulle
et qui ne va rien m'apporter
mais je suis en train
de développer
la valeur de Dieu
la valeur de Christ en moi
gloire à Dieu
et qui est le meilleur